game we got a live show bombshell to
drop on you right now just added a
second show at the Vogel theater August
11th over there in Red Bank New Jersey
grab some ticks and come see the boys
yeah shout out to the Army garbage we
sold it out in four days so we added a
second show get those tickets before
they're gone because they're gonna go we
love yous also May 24th will be in
Louisville Kentucky there you go uh then
June 14th 15th we're going to be in
Cleveland Ohio and Columbus Ohio then
again back to Red Bank New Jersey get
those tickets we love you be adding
dates welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit there with your
favorite comedians and we find it at the
group to be classy aren't you just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in a new
edition baby living high on the hog she
just got back from spring break okay
ankle bracelet should be off sometime
around Labor Day good for her jammed up
down there they'll screw around down
there in Miami Beach today that Toby
Mike Carlos is coming at you from right
next to me unamused this week so we're
gonna miss him
I'm kicking things off in a new studio
just the old-fashioned way he is the CEO
of Ru garbage he's an international
businessman and he's my best pal in the
whole wide world give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan hey what's up gang uh thanks
for tuning in as always please make sure
your rate of you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are cooking and
obviously uh I'd be remiss if I didn't
mention the greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage baby
check it out you got bonus episodes you
get hard feelings you get a Shia crap
ton of content on here check it out it's
a good time gang check it out how about
a nice quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works those ones Works
those twos crosses them T's dots them
eyes now you get a little peek at him
with the Toby cam give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen what's up dude
what's up did you guys hear the news
what's that that our guests won all-time
dude at the homie Awards this year
the biggest piece of Dirtbag trash I've
ever seen in my life
gang the long hair ain't lying we got a
goddamn fan favorite in the room
[Laughter]
that has coffee this is coffee baby this
is coffee brother that's insane I got a
life hack for your fans baby I this is
cold brew Nitro Brew Coffee Starbucks
7-Eleven it is a game changer Game
Changer it changed my whole [__] life
and I'm here to tell you about it I used
to feel like [__] now I feel much worse
but I used to feel like I got 20 ounces
of free cold brew this is like 30 ounces
of cold brew that's too much and they
don't it they [__] me on this one
because they're always out the gate
they're always trying to get me but if
they wouldn't take a check
it's my mom's check she said I could
have it paid them in a rolls of quarters
Oh I thought I had one in my pocket I'd
use the bodega last night why would you
have rolls of course without selling
merch in [__] Tulsa
yeah so I was somebody thought it'd be
funny to pay me in all quarters and I
was just like just give me the [__]
coin I need it I need every dime I can
get gang he's one of our absolute
favorites we love them you love the best
and he has a brand new special out right
now on his YouTube page takar Noir give
it up for top of the car everybody
thanks for having me back boys you're on
you're on he's back I will say this new
studio is changing Boys The Vibes in
here when the mics are off they don't
look at each other
it's gone to [__] sit and eat my too
much money now it's over the Toby cam
ruined everything let's show it to [__]
when they got the Toby cam they were
Jumping the Shark me and him are [__]
swinging around and stuff
we're suspended
so what kind of mayonnaise you like okay
sitting on pelotons
real snobby
buddy how the hell are you I'm good dude
I'm good I just got a little house in
L.A I'm here I'm back here I'm back in
town to get my cats
I feel like I'm in a like a movie like
like a dumb ass like
a Seth Rogen yeah you gotta I gotta go
back and get my cats I gotta I'm coming
back for my cats time to car starting
dudes where's my cash let's go let's
write this script Toby get on it man
what are you doing over there give us
the back story you moved out to LA
you're out in La so you're buying it one
place land owner yeah you own property
in Los Angeles well yeah actually it is
County it is County not City County
uh cell number 328.
I haven't I think it's full of rattlers
but I think it's gonna be nice they
don't do much testing out there anymore
so you should be all right
you ain't gonna need that microwave boy
[Laughter]
why is the ice keep melting
oh that's great where's the spot at oh
in uh East L.A Boyle Heights area yeah
yeah I can't get too specifically these
psychos come out of the Woodworks I
think it might be a bad neighborhood I
don't know I haven't heard great things
about each delay yeah I tend to live in
places that the rappers are uh yeah I
like to talk about uh have you picked
aside yet Crips should have blood they
do make you big he isn't all blue yeah
yeah I made my choice so what was that
process
joining the gang
what's your credit like I got good
credit okay good credit because uh I did
I opened two credit cards like within
the last two or three years but I've
always paid two weeks before you walked
in yeah yeah I didn't know I had a
Southwest credit card that I just kept
open I think that might be you think
that's the trashiest thing it's not
classy yeah Southwest Southwest is a
rough one Southwest I think I don't know
if the other ones off or if like I don't
think
to your credit card I don't think
there's a frontier they might though we
should look that up I think there is a
spirit credit card they all have one
they have I mean it's yeah yeah but
having one would be [__] did they get
you on the plane did you sign up for it
on the plane no no no no no I was uh I
had been here in comics [__] about they
were like these idiots don't use their
points or whatever and I was like oh I
should be doing that and then I lived in
Chicago so there was a bunch of
Southwest flights out here it doesn't
work yeah it's tough out here there's
barely
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's all right uh but isn't that
something a couple dirt bags like us end
up in a [__] nice Centurion Lounge
getting blackout drunk on free boots
filling up here Big Goal cup
yeah they let me bring this in there
just fill her up I have done that move
at Delta lounges you can have her little
Spritz in there
I've poured an old fashioned to go cup
out of the Delta Lounge really and
taking that on the plane with me yeah
you feel like a dirtbag though you're
gonna feel like a dirtbag yeah I did
that and then I have a crown that's like
loose or something that just pops out of
everyone's while I had my little cup and
then move something pops out just pops
out everyone it's a post that's broken I
shouldn't say this she didn't tell the
real estate agent they were gonna be
worried about me yeah this showed up
that's your credit I got a loose Crown I
can take that component if you want me
to scrap it I was just getting on the
plane with the [__] tooth that just
fell out and like [__] a whiskey you
just don't feel you know you got the
crown no I gotta get it fixed it's too
much of a process and I was filming the
special and I was like I just it falls
out and I just jam it back in there and
it's also like
he's back in his head it is so lame
that's got it thank you yeah it's I
don't think it stinks [__] do you take
it out and brush it and then put it back
in no no because it's like it is stuck
up there but if I eat like jello or
something
I've been hanging out Jello all the time
no I haven't had jealous I've been
hitting up these retirement communities
I'm living large are you gonna finish
your Jiggler
I've been spending a lot of time in the
hospital lately I'm not doing too well
fellas
things are going great
it's like I gotta get a flapper on it
but I I was like oh maybe I'll just do
that that's not is that a real word I
think the guy said it was a flapper I
don't think he was a real dog Yosemite
Sam what tractor trailers have on them
yeah it's like a mud flap yeah it's like
it's like a clipping yeah the doctor
said I need to do hickey
my insurance don't pay for
whatchamacallits
dude I feel like you're one whiskey sour
away from just crazy gluing it down I
know I've
that's what they did for me the first
time and then
cement in there they did they put some
in there Quikrete they really they
really do car wash they were like this
one should last you a couple months I
took I was eating gummy worms one night
and it just popped out and I was like
God damn it and then I tried to go back
and I was like can you just submit me
back up and they were like you really
shouldn't because you got me worms one
night
oh it was
uh fine where the I'm trying to think of
an early bird gets the word
yeah no but it's uh I didn't want to be
toothless though because I was like well
stav already does that yes I can't be
the knockoff toothless shark so it's
tough you know can you see it though
like would you be able to see it if what
do you oh you'd be able to see it here
there oh okay it's it's a it's a primary
yeah yeah it's a second row it's one of
the it's not mainly it's a series
regular
it's getting on Weekend Update everyone
God damn it throwing rocks tonight boys
Good Times
baby buddy congratulations on the
special thank you very much man
hopefully I can get some eyes on it yeah
baby and some ears garbage
one of my favorite guys I love you boys
and uh it's it's through 800 pound
gorilla so I'm gonna be posting clips of
it on my Instagram and stuff so give me
a little give me a little following yeah
I think most of your people already
follow me you have one of my favorite
things you were reading the comments and
they were like this guy's the biggest
piece of trash when you come into my
face it's true man it's true I've I've
gotten more from you guys as fans than
anybody that's right good people they're
the best by the way I gotta I was
looking at the 7-Eleven company I
remembered I got a bone to pick I almost
brought this [__] in here you said the
7-Eleven pizza is good yeah right yeah
are you out of your [__] mind that is
the one I'm a piece of [__] and I eat
other 7-Eleven [__] the pizza is the one
thing that [__] sucks you eat the
wings I eat the wings the wings are
pretty bad actually the wings are a
little tough but you know what's really
good is those mini tacos
right those things
I think we can agree it's all bad yeah I
like the twit like the the little like
roller thing yeah like the taquitos or
like the actual chicken roller or
whatever cheeseburger hot dog's pretty
good too yeah cheeseburger hot dog so
it's a filet mignon hot dogs
hot dog
yeah it's good that's one of those that
scared me I don't like the idea of the
combo happening
cross pollination I don't mess with it
that's supposed to mix your cheeseburger
and your hot dog cheeseburger
I don't know I don't know what what kind
of household you were raised in not in
my house baby uh listen the Old
Testament and our burgers are like I
don't have the most refined palette I'm
gonna lead off I'm saying I don't either
I enjoy that piece I don't mind the
pizza I couldn't believe it I'll do it
sober from time to time if I'm in a pin
I'm mostly drunk when I've had I've
mostly been banged up I've done it drunk
yeah we're not getting it for brunch
we're not [__] idiots well you just
said it's over sometimes it's over I've
had a wild move I've had it sober too I
had it recently because that's that's
how I got my whole 7-Eleven thing going
was next to my in-laws place there's a
7-Eleven that has this uh cold brew
coffee and you sneak a little Big Gulp
and you pour that in there they charge
you like a dollar wait all right so
what's this game you're running this
game I don't they don't sell clothes
this isn't supposed to be in here
legally I ain't allowed to happen I
shouldn't even be saying this [__]
you guys aren't cops I do think they're
on to me a little bit because some of
the 7-Elevens microwave
there's a guy cooking crack over there
yeah it is true you can kind of get away
with anything
it's wild that they still have like the
condiment bar
in your town yeah yeah yeah yeah
7-Eleven pickles you're in a bad spot
yeah that's tough they lock everything
up now too they do not the one not the
one by Uh Oh you mean like the deodorant
and [__] no even though like the
condiments no no okay I ain't gonna say
I get my olives for my martinis there
[Laughter]
the one in the West Village they have
all the drinks locked up oh everything
is locked up that's insane yeah that's
all I didn't know they sold deodorant at
seven I did know that the blues was
locked up because everything yeah I've
had to ask them to when you're like
asking a like a guy this is like an old
Indian man to take out a [__] giant
Lime-A-Rita for you I don't like that
I'm feeling good they have to get you
know I have like a black cherry white
yeah you feel a real dude real real
dainty about your choices
I've never related to anything anybody
said more than what you just said I had
to do exactly dirt pack alcoholics [__]
it I was going golfing and I had to be
like hey can you give me white claw and
the guy's just like what flavor that
sucks
he grabs when you're like no no I don't
like the guy I don't like the Ruby grape
uh do you have a black cherry or lie I
do a lie yeah I like them because they
[__] me up and I get to keep my figure
yeah exactly I gotta be I gotta stay
beautiful for this Industries
shout out to the white clothes all black
cherry by the way I don't know if you
noticed that I do like that's all we
[__] with the black cherry I'm a mango
man I don't mind the mango Mango's not
uh like top three flavor though I don't
think I think they do like lemon lime
black cherry what's the other and uh uh
raspberry yeah
grapefruits I think after the first
three yeah it don't matter it don't
matter yeah turpentine yeah I just don't
like the lime ones those ones are really
real lime guy yeah I'm not at a certain
point I'll drink lettuce flavored I
don't give a [__] [__] keep them
coming [__] make it white claw
the first green this man's had
claw lettuce Romaine how's the Romaine
white claw please
give us yes please give us the scoop on
the house so uh yeah we got this [__]
East L.A house dude it's crazy the
process is nuts and we had to write a
letter and be like hey we like the house
like if somebody else had put in an
offer and like it's so competitive out
there it's [__] tough dude getting
the house is tough I don't know how so
to get a house I don't know I feel like
you have to get Authority for like
someone has to like call your parents or
something yeah I don't know who like do
you just call the Bro the landlord and
go or the landlord to call them broker
and go I want to make it off so you guys
are driving around looking we got a real
estate dude we had this real estate
agent we met this lady from our uh on
our honeymoon we met this lady who at
dinner one night who was like my mom's a
real estate agent and then when she
started working with us and she was
brutal she she was just brutal she's
showing us [__] holes we accidentally
walked into somebody's house once and
they were just like
and she was like oh that's not the place
actually that we were supposed to go to
and it was like a dangerous neighborhood
too it was [__] up
you just hear gunshots
shaking her broom at us the market out
there if you want to live in like
Highland Park or something there are
places there they they sell them as like
they'll be like this is perfect for
people who love HGTV they mean like
Fixer-Upper [__] yeah but I was looking
at places million dollars recently on
fire like
literally the pictures you can see smoke
some older yeah
all right we'll take two grand off the
price
but it's a pain in the ass and then you
find out like you get to the process of
like oh we put an offer down then an
inspection comes back that's all [__]
up they're like the electricity's
hamsters on Wheels they have covered and
they tell you it's all good they have to
tell you they have to tell you it's not
all no I mean they don't they come come
now the inspector is a third party yeah
in fact there's like a bipartisan
but that's after they post it or List it
or whatever right yeah it's all good
yeah they don't even tell you anything
but it's like as is [__] you I think
it's the offer can you then make an
offer continue to jump on an inspection
okay I think dude people need to learn
this [__] for real because like if you
can do it like you don't need as much
money as you as I as you thought or
maybe I'm gonna go broken about I might
be [__] actually this tooth might ruin
my life it's gonna cost me everything
but uh no if you if you put like you can
put like five percent down on a house
and then do we we put a little more just
because you're more likely to get it
but uh yeah you do that then the
inspection goes through and then they're
like one of them we we were like super
excited about it it had an extra unit in
the back that we could have rented out
and so I make a little bit cash cash off
the books yeah yeah yeah I have a buddy
living there you get Toby out there I'm
down L.A Toby gotta Kick the raccoons
out first
okay let's talk about bass turn up the
base let's talk about turning a luggage
game on its head and making sure he
could fit a nice pair of shoes in there
and a couple extra outfits yes sir
because I get jammed up with the rolly
bags and all this crap that base bag
they sent us is all right yeah you're
like a new guy walking through the
tournament I feel like Mary Poppins
walking around I got a whole family in
that day yeah hopefully fantastic you
got a whole compartment for snacks at
the bottom healthy snacks that is it
ain't bad baby shout out to base uh yeah
the bags truly have it all uh 360 degree
gliding Wheels a cushioned handle which
uh we have the duffel bags Tom Cassidy
was rolling around with the bass yes you
want the base 360 John got a nice little
gripped handle very nice it was all the
talk at the terminal it was uh built-in
weight indicator washable bags for your
dirty clothes tons of interior pockets
for all your Essentials in case you're
already worried about messing up your
new brand your Brand New Bag base was
created to look even better with miles
so go ahead Chuck it in that overhead
bid elbow smash eight knee dropping
whatever you gotta do baby there you go
right now base is offering our listeners
here's the turkey 15 off your first
purchase by visiting basetravel.com
garbage it's spelled out differently
gang cause they're fancy
b-e-i-s travel.com garbage go to
basetravel.com garbage for 15 off your
first purchase at space travel
b-e-i-stravel.com garbage do it yeah
okay let's talk about mint mobile mint
mobile Daddy-o you know who's a cool guy
who Ryan Reynolds Ryan Reynolds you know
who formerly owned the company Ryan
Reynolds Ryan Reynolds sold it to a big
company you know what they did kept the
same fantastic deals that they've been
doing for years 15 a month yep for your
internet for your phone plan yeah make
sure uh the better choice for your wild
save money every month by switching them
in Mobile I've said it once I set a 10
000 freaking times you know I'm serious
when I'm using freaking my wife's been
using it for years it's Fran fan
freaking tastic it's easy peasy you buy
it they sent it right to the house it's
a it's a normal phone normal phone plan
just cut out the middle man come on
brick and mortar that's why they passed
the savings on to the consumer uh-huh
switching could have been easier keep
your same phone your phone number and
all your contacts the only thing that
changes is your bill and a couple more
shekels in your pocket at the end of the
month Daddio do it to get your new
Wireless plan just for for just 15 bucks
a month and get that plan shipped right
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage call your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
midmobile.com garbage do it do it there
is dude it is funny like have once you
have a place there's I saw a spider in
the garage I was like God damn it like
this [__] sucks
this goddamn spider I kill this spider
now or he's going to be part of my life
forever yeah
hey you ball [__]
a one-on-one for the house check it out
winner
this guy's got all the moves man
how are you gonna stop someone with
eight legs
he's spitting the ball on him
how did he win God damn it my wife's
pissed she's dating him now he's just
sitting on the ground holding your ankle
ah all right so what is the is the house
a fixer-upper do you need to do some
work too it's all I couldn't do I told
my wife because one of the places we
looked at it was going to take like 100
Grand of work and her whole selling
point was like there's a pool table and
I was like I can I'll buy them I'll buy
a pool table I'll steal a pool table
yeah what house comes with the pool
table I know that's right they left this
pool yeah they don't want to move it
they're like a thousand yeah no that was
them being like [__] you I don't want to
move a goddamn pool table and also this
pool table sucks [__] of course if it
was good they take it yeah of course but
uh that was like her seven ball yeah
yeah you just have to play [__] 14
balls all the time I don't have cash for
no damn seven they don't sell the seven
by itself
I can't just get it seven
I'm looking for a guy with two sevens
I'm sorry have you ever been to a store
and seen a loose seven ball rolling
around because I'm trying to stealing
from the bar and [__]
keep getting caught
no it's it's uh no it was TurnKey the
only thing was like there's a couple
things like the lights were [__] up
and I had to like figure that out
because they were like fluorescent like
it felt like being in a Walmart at night
I was like God damn we never saw it at
night and I was like digging in the roof
to try to fix it I was like I don't know
what the [__] I'm doing so I had to hire
a taskrabbit that which hey I I just
started leaning on that a little bit
it's fantastic yeah why try to fake like
you know what you're doing but you feel
like such a [__] wait so all the lights
yeah yeah they were LED like fluorescent
it felt it was tough your house have
drop ceiling in it what's that does your
house have drop ceiling in it drop
ceiling
I don't know but he's taking offense to
it what the [__] did you just say to me
tell me I'm a homeowner you can't talk
to me like that anymore
[Laughter]
[__] so what if a spider's gonna own in
a couple of weeks what the [__] did you
just say like the tile ceiling in an
office because that's what it sounds
like with the lights yeah I think it
does
but I'm still pissed
uh no but you feel like when I lived
here I would just have my buddy Tim come
and fix it for me yeah and you know I
just buy it
shout out to him and then uh it but
there I'm like oh I don't have like a
handy buddy around and my wife is like
what if you asked Zach and I was like
I'm not gonna ask Zach just some random
buddy of mine I was like don't people
yeah yeah so then I I just had to call
this taskrabbit and like when the guy's
there in your home it just feels like
[__] you're just doing push-ups yeah I
was like trying to do [__] around the
house I was like I'm doing stuff too
actually but
like playing with the dishwasher and
[__]
I don't know what I'm doing I just had a
guy come our a drawer in our kitchen got
so stuck something fell behind it and we
couldn't close it and days I couldn't I
couldn't get it off the I could not get
it that's a tough
dude I'm telling you so I I go [__] so
then my wife unbeknownst to me asks uh
one of the guy who works in the building
there's like a you know a couple guys
that live there they're like under the
super or whatever he comes up and
they're like this like Eastern European
guy and I don't know what he's there but
he's like I'm here to fix the drawer and
I'm like oh dude I'm in like I'm in like
my little [__] little [__] bike
shorts I got my [__] wiener tucked in
and he comes in and thank God I save
face because he couldn't get it he tried
for like an hour couldn't get it he had
another guy come up with him and
couldn't get it and then they found they
looked on YouTube to figure it out I
went all right I'm not I don't know my
wife I go see that's why I couldn't get
it that's great that's it gives me an
idea that could be a business you can't
do something so you hire a guy he's like
dude I don't
she [__] you
I
I can't get him
this is good stuff cut this Toby we
gotta use this
making money here baby
um it's rough I like wanted to play
video games while he was there and I was
like I can't do that yeah you can't
that's no good I just had to pretend I
was working on my computer for a little
bit just loudly hit it yeah I'm actually
a writer
sitting there watching the Mandalorian
helmet on
all right sorry well congratulations
yeah thank you boys that's great I'm
happy for you you're [__] goddamn
Landing that's crazy what's the lawn
situation lawn uh there's not much of a
lawn it's like it's two little like
patches of dirt basically we have a big
backyard though like a decent sized
backyard okay but it's all [__] up
yeah it's there's no right there it's
like weeds and [__] we gotta go back
there's you gotta trees that are falling
over uh it's a it's probably gonna do
that yourself or you're gonna hot no
yeah no the things I could do myself I
thought were the lights and I couldn't
so now I've played video games I can
chill I can make cocktails hey that's
all that's all you need baby hey you
boys want a martini yeah I felt bad the
guy got there and I woke up 20 minutes
late too he was just sitting in the
[__] yard like in the driveway he's
just eating up cash Burn yeah burning up
cash where was your wife was she home or
she at work she was home but we don't
have a doorbell there's a little weird
problems there's little there's all when
you [__] do when you is there a house
look we're gonna put some walls up
pretty soon
it's only got three we're gonna get a
roof on this place I guarantee it it's a
very open floor plan yeah dude we hired
this roofer and he is damn he had to get
a roofer we had to get a roofer should
do to get in there got to get a roofer
we had to have somebody come do like a
plumbing inspection General inspection
Foundation inspection it's all it's all
[__] expensive too everybody costs
like 500 bucks and the roofer guy all he
did for [__] 500 because we had to
get him separate he sends us a diagram
and it just it's a picture of the roof
and it says old good bad that's all yeah
I can see that yeah and then we had the
venmo in 500 bucks in his venmo picture
I swear to God was a picture of him
holding a shotgun pointed at the camera
and my wife was like who the [__] is
like it was crazy I don't think he's a
roofer man yeah yeah 500 bones uh any
any varmints back there because you're
because you're crazy cats there's cats
that roam around oh that's okay yeah I
like see it's fun to see him are your
cats indoor cats or indoor cats they
can't handle the outside good that's why
I'm terrified about [__] taking them
back it's gonna be brutal have you flown
with cats before no no no it's my
nightmare I really wish I could have I
did I just learned there's like a
service well that where they'll do this
for you
oh I don't know I may probably Drive
probably Drive yeah I mean you could
knock that out in a week or whatever
yeah yeah they hate the outside they're
stupid they're so [__] dumb and
worthless
that's I was just talking to my buddy
about this they think they're such hot
[__] dude oh they got such attitude in
their house and then you pop their head
outside and they're like
[Laughter]
any coyotes or anything like that
mountain lions I haven't seen any [__]
like that we're not in the mountains
though we're not anywhere no what's
behind you what is behind us just a
street okay just a big old just a bunch
of little streets driveway driveway
garage garage no garage door opener
though
I got it I was seeing if I can get that
installed but you got to have like a
plug that's like the right way this is
all [__] that like every little thing
we've had to do it's like you just gotta
plan on spending like a grand yeah yeah
whatever everything's a thousand and how
many bedrooms is it three
three br's baby so hey you boys got a
space to stay Toby's written out the
other room have a good time yeah I might
make one into a studio what uh what do
you do in the garage you're gonna be
parking the car in the garage
it's not a good spot for it floods real
bad
it does flood and it has been raining a
[__] load in L.A so it stinks in there
okay it's a stinky garage but you drove
the car out I assume I drove the car I
drove the car across country yeah man I
didn't know that 2010 Toyota Corolla
baby no [__] a reliable vehicle started
right at the end of the drive it started
making a weird [__] noise and it just
stuck around sucks dude did you do it by
yourself me and Tim McLaughlin drove out
oh shout out to Tim Timmy baby yeah you
wrote out we went to Vegas we did some
shows along the way then we stopped in
Vegas right I remember that yeah yeah
great time I want to go across I want to
get an RV I'm putting this out in the
world RV are you garbage across the
across the country I'll meet you out
there why wouldn't you want to do that
that would be a blaze it's fun it does
kind of suck though sure
there was one drive we did that was like
Tim was pissed because he didn't know
that it was going to be a 14-hour drive
day and we had done a show and then we
got to go to bed at like [__] now and
get up at four in the morning but you
want a deadline to get out there yeah
because well no I was just trying to set
up shows that was how I [__] up I set
up shows every night 14. every other
night should have done every other night
but it just worked out that way
yeah but it's it was it was cool though
it was an experience for sure yeah you
see this beautiful land yeah man it's uh
it's crazy you see some of the parts
like of Utah and [__] are nuts they're
just like things you've I would have
never seen before and like driving from
there to Vegas in Vegas to LA I was like
God damn yeah like it's just beautiful
La is nice it's a it's a pretty looking
drive it started raining as we were
getting into LA and people there don't
know how to [__] drive in the rain so
it took us like four extra hours to
drive through but uh no it's a beautiful
little Drive beautiful little Drive boy
we do it do it all right cross country
the 2032 tour how about that
the 2032 tour that's what nine years
from now oh nine years okay I'll put you
in a rascal or something tell you the
whole time
but yeah put you in one of those [__]
U-Haul trailers so his eyes went crossed
there that was crazy he's not a numbers
guy it freaked me I thought you were
just naming it
wait you think I named the tour the 2023
tour and it was in a different year yeah
I didn't know okay fair enough you'll
lost me for a second I apologize uh Gang
This is a uh not a family episode but we
got company Mr cousin Tommy in a
building here of course uh so we go over
we ask your garbage questions gang when
you sign up for patreon we will answer
your garbage question on the air it's
just the best way to do it uh patreon
gets the first crack at it let's see
here uh
um hit us Skippy this one's from Calvin
uh is it garbage to play air hockey at
the arcade while the machine is off but
the puck was left out yes
it doesn't [__] hit just as you want
it talk about the winner takes off oh
yeah we used to do that at my old
apartment in college because we played
beer pong on the air hockey table and it
broke the thing one game immediately one
game immediately we toasted the [__]
air hockey game that's pretty cool an
air hockey table in college oh yeah
that's awesome I mean that's that [__]
where you're like you're like we're
gonna use this all the time and then we
just didn't but uh we had a ping-pong
tail it was sick but we would often
because it broke we were just like man
why is this table suck and then we're
like oh yeah the Air's not coming down
yeah yeah that was big as a kid and if
you if you could get a ball outside you
I know you're a papa shot guy yeah but
if you the game was you could somehow
get your hands on a papa shop ball oh
yeah it was like you would be dribbling
around the arcade or just [__]
[__] around with it and you obviously
had to throw it back in which sucks
there was nothing cooler back in the day
than the mini basketball oh yeah man and
they had like the Sixers they had the
Bulls yeah one of those in your own oh
baby they were living large permanent
you feel like Jordan yeah I used to
shoot one of those into a hamper I was
like yeah
you I assume were a Nerf kid a Nerf
basketball oh yeah I love that I do that
right now truly the first time
the first thing I put up in my house was
a goal and like a little Nerf ball thing
do you remember no windows no no no yeah
they did it didn't come with Windows
spiders everywhere
check it out babe got the net off here
Duncan I [__] own this place
I only saw one kid that had one so the
spiders like I got next it was the
hamper that you would shoot your clothes
in yes with the bat and then it fell
into the net that was rich kid [__] one
they weren't Rich I just remember that's
what you would see in the movies yeah
that's like blank checks yeah exactly
first purchase baby yeah those things
were all right that was I remember being
like damn I am on the fireman Saved by
the Bell or something yeah you gotta
every parent should buy their kids
race car bed something look it up make
it nice never I tell you what that air
hockey when I was a kid that technology
blew my [__] brains off
I couldn't believe how it just hovered
right above there it was so smooth
moving around it's cool I [__] love
it in your hockey table air hockey we
just played right up mine where did we
play in Disney uh Orlando the house we
rented had a [__] game room that's
awesome yeah it wasn't a strange thing
right
it wasn't because the table wasn't great
the ball was great yeah it kept flipping
off the [__] table [__] I played it
we played it David I played at Dave and
Busters right yeah yeah I know my
bachelor party we found a bar actually
I'm gonna go back because we're going
back I'm going back to New Orleans I'm
gonna find this bar just because it has
a sick Iraqi table damn light it up baby
you are a big
guy oh yeah that's how I was raised
sounds like a lot going on there Tommy I
got a lot of big plans in the future I'm
gonna run the table in a [__] air
hockey I'm going back to I'm going back
to New Orleans just to find that ball I
gotta find that that is like a game that
no one is really proud of you for being
like it's not cool to be air hockey yeah
yeah like there's no movies like how
there's movies about like guys who are
good at pool or whatever you hustle
people sure but you can't roll up to an
air hockey table with your own
little puck thing and then you're like
uh I got Nick got a custom handle
everybody's like oh [__] I like using it
with uh when you just put the two
fingers in there that's when you feel
cool oh yeah instead of holding the
thing yeah that's the that type of
strategy I would [__] your whole life
can you try that you pull that [__] on
you pull that two-finger [__] [__] on
my damn [__] on me you disrespect me
with like that comment you coming to car
with the two fingers [__] your life up
all right you were right over here I'm
right over top and I'm covering my bases
old school once I get the stop I go
your life is over
sorry just paint you and call you a
[__]
sorry my life time I just had a
flashback can't be just talking about
butcher box butcher box butcher box
butcher box let's quit screwing around
let's talk about butcher box let's talk
about premium meat being sent right to
your door at your disposal anytime you
want to have it I'm talking high quality
[__] here we're talking free range we're
talking wild caught wow all right yeah
we're talking grass-fed grass finish
beef we're talking about delicious Meats
my freezer is stocked with butcher box
yeah and we use it all the time the bird
takes it out in the morning lets it thaw
out come home right on the grill like
the 80s baby all right I'll get your
nutrition on point with meat you can
trust butcher box sends humanely raised
Cuts with no antibiotics or hormones
added to your meat at all you can even
customize your butcher box to suit your
needs and get exactly the right kind of
meats and all your favorite meals I let
them choose because they know what
they're doing they know what's selling
they know what's moving yeah me too I
like when somebody picks it pick it up
it's like go to your neighborhood but
you're here send me the Box do it up get
a pork loin you get some cutlets you get
this you get that it's nice it's
fantastic baby you know me I love that
butcher box uh here's where things get
really good butcher box is giving us a
special deal as usual they always blow
my tits off sign up today using code ayg
to receive ground beef for a year plus
20 bucks off your first order what are
we talking about here that's two pounds
of ground beef free in every box for a
year plus 20 bucks off your first order
when you sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg I mean that's not use code ayg
that's butcherbox.com
ayg promo code ayg do it gang we love
you now back to the show back to the
show uh all right this isn't a question
this is from Sean I just saw something
truly spectacular would love to get
[__] Tommy's Insight Sunny D vodka
seltzers you've seen these no what yeah
that's [__] up that's like a kids
thing you can feel the burn into my
throat they're gonna do uh what are
those juice pouches or whatever oh Capri
Sun Capri Sun visor right they have
something that would be actually pretty
good Sunny D vodka seltzers Sunny Deepak
vodka juice
on that they've been jammed up for like
30 years this could bring them back they
need to come back yeah there's nobody's
talking with Sunny D anymore no what's
it because it's like not even really
juice right nobody's giving that four
kids it's not in the cooler it's just in
the aisle you see that next yeah yeah
that's true it's next to the like the
cement yeah
get it at the Depot that and there's
something else I'm I'm butchering the
name tapachico Topo Chicos not Topo
Chico the Tropicana no no not Tropicana
there's another Tropic Thunder no good
movie though uh great movie there's
another like a Sunny D that's always
with SunnyD
yeah I think I know what you do high C
is that it no no no I love it
dare you sir no one I don't think people
aren't probably buying their kids Sunny
D anymore now like the health thing has
changed I was a 90s product yeah
for sure no that's over but so this is
just playing to the people that drive
it's fine to us yeah the people that
drank it as kids
I made a bad idea I'll probably drink
some you turn around
[Laughter]
uh all right let's see here uh this is
from Nikki never had one red is a
garbage you just sleep with a comforter
and no sheets it just feels wrong
I don't have a shiny sheet you don't
have any sheets no like sheets on the
bed or no or is he talking like a top
sheet is that what they're called I
think he's saying raw mattress with a
yeah that is garbage that's wild but
listen it's like sleeping in your jeans
every once in a while it feels really
good oh yeah I do that every night I
don't know I blackout every night
it feels good just be like like if for
some reason you're in the middle of
washing the sheets I don't get I don't
get to get away with it much yeah it's
dirty though I know it's something about
an actress is dirty you're dirty yeah
it's sometimes sometimes no pillowcase
it just feels good I don't know why I I
get it look how you like to sleep on the
bottom like sleep sideways on the bed
sometimes what you ever do that just in
the middle of the day just like lay down
sideways middle of the day I'll give you
if you [__] nah I'm not passing out
like getting ready to go sideways yeah
all right I'll give you that then I
don't know about that
I like how you pulled back for a bit
Yeah I changed my mind never mind
what's the next [__] question anyway
that's why I do it because the cats are
on the good parts of the bed so then
I'll sleep I'll like lay down between
them
I've done that put yourself out of that
one
it was really they were laser beams all
around me on that one by the skinny or
dead tooth
guys that's where we started you have
skin on your dead tooth I'm really
worried
I got a scab on my tooth it's got hair
growing out of it that would be some
[__] you say you'd probably be like I'm
all [__] up but I got skin on my teeth
yeah yeah I woke up the other day
my tooth got an [__]
uh I see you sucking on it a little bit
Yeah I find myself pushing it it's that
I'm pushing it all the time isn't it
keeping it up there this is going to
sound real dirt bag obviously those
things Jamie up and I've had situations
like that where it kind of it it's like
a security blanket it feels good like
sucking stuff out of it every once in a
while I love that no I don't I know what
you mean I don't feel that about this I
don't know no it sucks dude because it's
like a screw they're just yeah I have
dental real I don't know I got Dental I
got Dental I've I finally got health
insurance too it's all through my wife's
company though I don't have any of that
[__] myself I went without any insurance
for a while yeah you gotta let it ride
you can buy a PS5 with that money baby
that's good American cash
if you go to the doctor and get I'll
check that one oh
or something
it's fine no but I had a I had a tooth
that was loose for a long time and I
used to suck on it all the time yeah
yeah it's it's there is a comfort in it
but once it pops out you're like oh [__]
yeah my life is bad yeah but tough luck
it's got a the real problem is it's so
it's a screw that's attached to it I
used to see that video that would play
as I was getting like uh work done as a
kid or whatever like a cavity or
whatever and they would just constantly
play that like the cartoon with that
cartoon but like with the screwed me out
that's what they want they want us all
get screws they want everybody to get
the implants the fake teeth
big teeth big teeth hey big teeth wants
to take all of our teeth and put it in
screws
oh
big enamel uh all right
let's see uh
uh I just wasn't from Jeff nodler shout
out to OG nodler shout out to him uh is
it garbage for Dad's prized possession
is an autographed football with the 97
Steelers on it every autograph is
actually a print of the autograph and
not actually
yep yep I had one of those I know that I
know those quite well I had a baseball
like that and it's like yeah man you
don't frame that yeah but can you really
tell yeah yeah well yes it looks pretty
it looks like a t-shirt or whatever yeah
a pen versus garbage you know
I mean even if it was signed it's not a
great look it's not the best but it's
better it's better for sure sure my
first baseball club was uh was a
pitcher's glove by uh Bruce Sutter and
it had his signature in it and did it
for about two years I was walking around
telling people that it was that's the I
remember the first time I had my brother
[__] blew me up is she written in
gold or whatever yeah I shattered my
reality it's game worn or whatever
you're [__] lost I remember my mom's
saying like now he signed that make sure
you take good care of it and I [__] him
with like sleep with it under my pillow
every night and our brother was like you
know we just got that at Sears right son
of a [__] dudes I meant to tell you
guys uh I went to the went to the
Islanders game recently you know
baseball games you'll see a kid with a
glove there was a kid in the crowd with
a goalie mitt but it wasn't the glove
side it was the blocker
I respect that don't [__] with that kid
good for him dude left and right
yeah you hear about that all the time
that's a cool kid right there God
imagine if it worked out that he got to
do it oh boy yeah he looked like a
genius
[__] Steal Your Girl babe
that's a good idea yeah well growing up
we played we would play like street
hockey and somebody had to be goalie so
you would use the hockey you would use a
baseball glove yeah as the as the man
that sounds like that would be the job
for the designated fat kid yep yep yeah
I played a lot of goalie and catcher in
my day yeah I was catcher it's nice
though you get to block up that net up
tough to get around can't eat your
sandwiches though
I say we take five we got a sandwich
break
okay you guys are all you guys are all
playing in a cul-de-sac delivery guy I
got an order for Henry
how'd you get Uber Eats out here
uh but somebody we stole it off of
somebody but we ended up with the waffle
like the we had one for like maybe a
year that's awesome and everybody wanted
to play goalie because yet we had yeah
sure you had the actual [__] thing it
felt like a real tough my buddy had the
uh they were they were like the kid
version but we had the pads remember
those leg pads sure they were like skin
color or like tan and they were Rubber
and they had the black foam on the
inside I had those yeah neighbor had
them they were all right man you got a
pair of those
how cool baby I felt like a rich kid
um all right let's see here this is Nick
uh ten dollar Bozo never had one red is
a garbage part of my family inheritance
includes an uncut sheet of two dollar
bills
which to me that I didn't even get that
I know that seems amazing yeah uncut
sheet of money there's always the two
dollar bill is the rarest of the bills
yeah yeah there's always a story of
somebody's aunt or uncle worked at the
mint and they started throwing them out
they were some [__] Prince or
something and yeah or the mint was
closing down so we got them all
inheritance though huh part of the
inheritance yeah that's a little yeah
yeah if you're writing that down like
billy gets the cheetah two dollar bill
yeah that's a little yeah the rest of it
wasn't a house on Shelter Island or
anything like that yeah yeah yeah you're
not you're not seeing a lot there's no
yacht in that one
because it gets the yacht you get the
two dollars you're getting the two
dollar bills he's getting the fake
autograph football
do you have any two dollar bills in your
possession I do not on me but in my
drawer because I put the down payments
yeah when you sell when you sell merge
people just want to hand you goofy ass
[__] sure yeah yeah yeah and so I some
people had a couple of them you gotta I
got I read a couple yeah I hate them I
don't know you already feel stupid you
have any good luck charms or anything
like that that not really I rabbit's
foot or anything no no no I don't
believe in Good Luck only bad luck only
hard times I got a dead tooth that I
carry around for uh bad hard luck these
are going too well two dollar bill in
there yeah no I don't I don't have any
of that stuff I don't think I have a I
have like a Reggie Miller Jersey that
I'll like I just have it in my house and
I think that's maybe good luck but yeah
I don't have any charms here's a
question now that you're a homeowner
what's your uh home protection plan what
do you got what do you got next to the
bed next to Oh you mean I'm gonna throw
my tooth out we have them
that's like uh we have this crazy sharp
knife yeah I got that screw on the two
you know come at them hot I feel like
you'd be like I got a bug zapper I
turned the cage off
buddy come get me if you want but you're
gonna lose that hand
I lure him into a puddle and then throw
it at him I got a shocking uh dog collar
I'm gonna throw around them
um
so you got a knife we got a pretty sick
knife that it's sharp as hell is it in
the kitchen it's in the kitchen right I
got nothing in the bedroom you got to
get something in the bedroom yeah yeah
maybe I'll get like a sword or something
I don't know I hadn't thought about it
you gotta get at least a little bag yeah
yeah maybe I'll get a baseball I mean
it's different from New York City or
whatever you're on the fifth floor yeah
yeah right there yeah that response time
out there I imagine you're waiting about
20-25 minutes yeah it's clean up at that
point we haven't uh a ring camera or
whatever so oh it's not set up right now
but it's there for sure you can post the
murder on Instagram
a couple weeks later get you get you
some some clicks I felt bad the neighbor
came up this is how it was like I think
it's a bad neighbor the neighbor came
over whatever the gas guy was setting
[__] up and he was like hey could you
check your ring camera some guy like
some kids like stole a bunch of [__] for
me the other day and I was like ah man I
don't want to hear that hey can you take
your ring cam someone murdered my wife
last night yeah plus he's turning it
into a snitch yeah
to your hands
I can't help you dude I'm busy right now
what bad neighborhood
you saw that spider too huh
hahaha
oh [__]
how was the rest of the properties
around you is it is it a lot of young
people moving in a lot of loud dogs no
young people
it's a lot of loud dogs you never see
but oh yeah you only hear these dogs and
when the mailman comes through they pop
off that mailman should be terrified
because he's like this dog next to us
they have this [__] tarp that's set
up uh so I can't see in their yard or
anything it looks like [__] and we're
gonna like try to paint it or something
because it's on our property this is a I
never wanted to be a guy who's like
that's our property or whatever but
having that tarps mine yeah but
um your neighbors have a tarp up they
got a little one like a blue car bright
green tarp they know that I know it
sucks but uh we just hear the dog
barking and ramming his head into the
target
crazy ass said try to get out
boys I'm touching go I'm gonna be honest
with you I keep thinking I'm gonna maybe
uh throw up so was this was this all did
you how come you guys decided to buy was
it investment it's good rent is so
[__] high in L.A okay investment we
want to start a family and [__] yeah you
know you got to do it you boys should
boys should jump in baby what's the
school what's the school district like
where you're at probably bad I don't
know I'm thinking about all that [__]
you said you wanted to start a fan I
didn't say they had to go to that good
school they're going to join the credits
yes exactly pick a side baby
oh if we buy a bunch of blue like baby
[__] they're like oh it's a boy it's
like no no no
that's our [__] baby
one of the schools I don't like it now I
don't [__] go to a school before I
buy that I'm not a [__] nerd
cool can I meet some of the teachers
how are you doing that also the kid's
not gonna go to school for at least
another if even if you know now at least
like five years yeah you got five six
seven years on you okay turn get that
tarp down yeah once that tarp comes down
we'll start talking about schools uh
a little bit but I ate some bad uh every
time you're in here you ate something
bad I know I [__] up what'd you do I
ate some bad chicken and rice I think
and it's been [__] me up for like a
day and a half where'd you get it just
some Bodega the random ass Deli it
sucked bad down I know dude you roll the
dice did you come back he's got a half a
while at a gas station
it turns out the way I lived my life
apparently the way I live my life you're
gonna throw up every once in a while
I'm that way with diarrhea yeah yeah
same it is okay with a dozen oysters
it's gonna be all right
um
that's not bad when you're drunk they're
all right did you uh have you hit any
places that you missed now that you've
been back did you go to like any of your
uh spots have I got I went to Canal bar
which is my favorite bar yeah I'm gonna
go to Turtles all the way down I love
that place that's the old five dollar
beer in a shot that I love shout out to
a five dollar beer and a shot yeah baby
I tried to go to this pizza place I love
but we got there they didn't have wine
anymore they like changed their business
and I was like [__] that like you got to
tell people they'd they put white out
over their wine list and I was like you
don't have booze and they were like oh
no we changed I was like okay we're
getting the [__] out of here what the
[__] did I come to this establishment
for what am I a nerd yeah and so we left
but yeah other than that what do you
mean you don't have turtle races anymore
I wish I was in town for the turtle race
I have yeah I want some money but that's
right what are you talking about right
no they put them uh it Turtles all the
way down on one Sunday a month they have
a shuffleboard table and they put two
turtles down and you buy a ticket for
one of the one of the other it's like
blue and red and they race and then you
win a free beer no way I'm going to
check that sick yeah yeah that's awesome
I saw the one where it's like they're
all in a circle like a small circle and
then you like lift up the bucket and
they have to whoever whatever one gets
outside the bigger Circle for like a
wrestling match yeah yeah and when
everyone crosses like the final oh
that's a good time really yeah when they
get the turtles from Tom they're in the
tank they got a turtle tank there really
I think you're just getting drunk in an
aquarium yeah
are you getting drunk at the pet shop
again I was getting [__] out how many
turtles are in there two there's only
two so they just same two races it's a
battle for the ages
they're gonna raise each other are they
big turtles no they're like medium-sized
Turtle I don't know what's a they're not
like giant [__] they're not like 100.
whatever
sea turtles I don't know
that's pretty cool all right let's do
one or two more here and then we gotta
get we gotta jump I'm sorry boys I might
be dying I'm sorry boys I [__] up I
thought I'd be all right
[__] oh man I love it no comment that uh
I suck this episode I'm warning you what
are you talking about I don't know I'm
my stomach's all [__] all right let's
see this one is from pilt OG have you
ever punched yourself in the eye
repeatedly to try to give yourself a
black eye so you look cool in Middle
School me either [__] yeah dude all the
time that is a great yeah God the things
you think will be gonna make you look
cool like that it will be interesting
like I remember I used to just like
sometimes just walk with a limp oh [__]
now something interesting is going on
yeah wait until these girls get a load
of this look at this somebody's gonna
ask me about my limp right what are
these broads see my Walker the black guy
thing I've definitely done that and I
tell you what though you do look cool
with the black eye you do not the first
day second three yeah yeah it's got a
it's like a new haircut for me you punch
yourself in the eye so you got a black
eye yeah that is wild I've never heard
of that yeah I like it though yeah it's
pretty cool maybe I'll do it tonight is
that what your girlfriend and told you
right you fell let me tell you you did
it to look cool you fell fatty you see
um all right let's see this is from Mark
is it garbage that your number one
criteria of buying dress pants is that
they're wrinkle free and stain free
always and I respect that that's a good
move you need stainless pants to do
Teflon Cheetos in the house or Cheetos
Cheetos
I can't even chew through these things
they're a little crunchy reusable
Cheetos ladies and gentlemen
guys has a brand new special about right
now to carnivore on his YouTube page do
yourself a favor go and check it check
it out gang support Tommy thanks so much
for having me boys
bunch of bunch of dates coming up go to
my website tomtakar.com and follow me at
tomtakhar love you guys this is the best
love you buddy what do you got for him
uh same thing we're all over the road uh
the tour is moving on we're announcing
more day shows are selling out get those
tickies if you snooze you lose gang we
love you to death and we'll see you next
week peace